[Music]
welcome to Chester Knights known further
to this as the one o'clock class part 2
okay because they're actually the one
o'clock class especially Karen now I'm
just kidding okay not my wife Karen as
far as I know anyway now people are
coming in droves and leaving in droves
well alright so as you all know because
you all subscribe to my youtube channel
although I noticed this YouTube channel
has over 100,000 subscribers and my
youtube channel has 6,000 plus tax
with very little tax because there's
more tax in Missouri I'm in Atlanta you
know there's so um you probably haven't
seen these games because you don't
subscribe to my channel because you're
the worst how you actually aren't the
worst because I know these kids alright
right you know what I'm talking about
okay so today we're going to look at the
games that I flirted the two-on-two
championship who is my partner I don't
remember now somehow Mike Hummer was the
director so things were sort of
suspicious for example the team that we
played in round one their board to was
higher rated than the board one when I
pointed that out comer was confused
language didn't really change things and
they ease it out hey you guys can leave
it like that
so I played a thirteen hundred round one
and my partner who shall remain unnamed
played a fourteen hundred about stuff
preparing okay we were racing to see who
would win first so the first game was
your favorite opening can they see that
or you want to do some white stuff yes
what's that
it's the French okay and in the French
defense when I'm white which isn't very
common because I don't blame you for
that often either take that's not
working okay about that hot I either
take or I play he five taking is the
exchange variation what's ePHI fault
advanced variation and since I was more
advanced than my opponent by about
double his rating
I played a five
that's a little more complicated okay
now most of you would play Bishop d6 or
Knight f6 then when I get off the floor
laughing I would take your pieces and
then I would bring you Kleenex but
you're busy crying and then you would
buy a copy of my book cry like a Grand
Master says you're not crying right okay
my opponent played c5 the usual move and
then I thought we were playing at
connect for tournament so I played c3 I
shook the ends and I laugh okay now
let's say the next game because I got
Connect four right ma'am okay he had six
hacked oh but this is a tic-tac-toe
tournament terrible okay so we kept
playing because Mike comer explained it
was a chess tournament
I couldn't tell by my opponents moves
you know what I'm saying down okay so
this is the most common position in the
advanced French because black is putting
a lot of pressure on d4 all of black is
attacking d4 so what did I do
I unprotected d4 I'm a grandmaster I
don't play that
so I played Bishop to d3 which is one of
the common moves and the idea is I want
to get my bishop out in Castle which I
did my opponent did not do that he did
that council okay he'd figure he'll
Castle the next game there's three
rounds now here it looks like black
kenwood upon by taking forever
and the class ends because it was
forever and that's a blunder it's very
well known maybe not to this class
because now white is winning who has the
right answer let's call it a render the
students Karen just a sec I'm getting a
text for my wife she gave the right
answer I did call him Kenan she thought
it was her you were the highest rated
player in the room who's not me much
higher than you which is true wait a
minute your brother's in here Marsh
who's higher rated all the kids or that
guy in the back add it up
that's right you this should be five
check I'm sure you're all thinking that
and then I'm attacking the Queen
that's called a double attack so I win
so did my opponent do that no okay
what most people do is they take once
that they stop this should be five check
by playing dish of d7 then they take the
pawn later pawn sacrifice okay it's your
favorite movie because it was so good
only one movie was better Wonder Woman
okay
he let's play my Wonder Woman not that's
the worst movie I've ever seen
not that well Greg Shaw how do you saw
it and said it was great yeah you know
people voted for Trump - okay so my
opponent made a mistake he played nine
ge7 his mistake was not realizing we're
playing bughouse when I played 96 check
oh okay
now night ge7 blocks his bishop this is
one of the problems black has in the
advanced French is black can't go there
because I take his Knight and after 9 g7
since his bishop can't move then I took
his pawn and he played Queen shanks and
his Queen was going to go on a journey
because Queen's going to move every move
gray and I Castle he played another bad
move g6 blue he should move his Knight
somewhere what's that
yeah we're yeah what did I say you're
the best had my fingers were possible I
like that okay g6 I attacked his queen
now this was very confusing to me my
genius audience here what do you think
black played not as genius as I thought
and he won you in the back the biggest
genius Queen would be fix the only safe
square for the Queen and therefore the
only good work
my opponent thought about six minutes I
don't know what he was thinking about I
wish I knew
snacking the Queen that's a good move
okay I shouldn't lie the children but
fathers made what I want okay or as far
as you're concerned it's like ten-week
sacrificing alright so he played Queen
b6 and I attacked his queen again what
were you guys sleeping today so I
thought he'd moved his queen and that's
what I would do but he sacrificed a pawn
he played the whole game without
wandering upon it's the longest
anybody's ever lasted so I should take
that pawn any way I want but I decided
to take with the knife so I have
discovered attacks with my knife now if
white moves his Knight next to move the
bishop is attacking the Queen you agree
so what one can he play that attacks
wave YCJA the movie should have Frank
ninety-five good answer Frank
so 95 is the right move then the
computer says whites up a pawn but not
totally totally totally winning but he
played Queen to d8 so he sacrificed to
fajn then retreated okay I asked to see
his passport what country was he from
now France he retreated okay now I
pinned his Knight which I taught the one
o'clock class and they remember what I
taught them okay and he took my knight
and I did something you've never heard
of called his mission sub you may know
it as in-between move you probably don't
know anything but he could not buy that
normally when somebody takes something
you take back as in Barney chess I take
you you take me yeah he was the worst
class in history you know he not going
but I didn't take his Knight I attached
something more important you the highest
rated player lowest rate of fire that's
for the one o'clock class terrible well
they did say the right move eventually
so the ship f6 attacking his rook now he
wants to fee in Cairo his bishop when he
played g6
but he sort of forgot about it he was
busy doing other stuff okay so I've been
kind of his bishop so ripped g8 white
were the work belongs now it's like a
funny story I've been married many times
and one of my marriages I don't know
which one one of my wives like to play
rich in English she was black and I said
it's not doing that you're not allowed
to ever play Rick g8 that it rating went
up see so if you play trip g8 with black
alive that's their good what should you
do with that working chest often Castle
she's my opponent point I'm going to
Castle once he plays River GA on that
side okay so it's the night did he take
my pawn like you would
why not write the very quiet this would
be five it's quiet because he said it
quietly yeah now he's in shock because I
said so and his Queens attacked so he
played Bishop g7 I could have seen
heavens rook but I developed a peace we
trained it is 90 to act he was knighted
okay now I wanted to heat this pawn I
liked that pawn that funds my friend
it makes his king and rook look sort of
silly
so I played 90 for defending my pawn he
took his pawn back and I moved this guy
and this guy and this guy and this guy
this guy in this guy these are the guys
I didn't move okay and I like the way
Paul Morphy plays chess even now and I
like to move all my pieces that get them
involved so I played a riff c1 okay now
he surprised me however he did prove
that his passport was authentic so what
did he play what move can black play to
prove he's from France what's the most
you can retreat the most ah that's why
you're not from France dude what'd you
say do you say Queen d7 you're so hosed
yeah now that's French okay the only
person worse than somebody who's French
is a member of our club French he agrees
but he works the post League if anything
all he can do his last on the camera
came here on my board okay so it's tough
being French now you'll notice I didn't
move my hook yet but I like to move all
my pieces so I pinned is not threatening
everything then he's created Queens he
likes to move his Queen a lot that's
most of us needs that now let's see who
the smartest person in the room is how
many times is black moved is Queen so
far I know the answer the answer is I
don't know
I don't know so that's correct the
funniest thing Frank ever heard you're
over there we're gonna get we're going
to Frank a minute if you ever stops
laughing I'll let you know all right so
he moved his queen many many times he
played Queen b6 queen c5 back to b6 back
to DA then he moved it to d4 then back
to GA that he traded Duggar daily so now
did blackwell of any of these pieces now
I took the Queen and I moved all my
pieces and they're all doing something
and my king is safe he didn't move any
of these pieces
he moved this one boo and he moved his
nine and that's came to attack twice
so what's funny is the computer which
counts the material to the Tyrael who's
the head of material you guys can do it
I have faith in you my comer doesn't
know because he can't live off the board
don't look on the board on the boards
ridiculous do we do that black stuff
lacks up one pawns accounting you guys
go to public school all right White has
six lines that black has six points when
I was in school six equals six so
nobody's up anything so normally when
nobody's up anything the computer says
equal yeah equal however White has a lot
of advantages white pieces are all
better than blacks pieces in whites King
is safer than blacks King and white has
a big threat here that you don't see so
if it was White's move what would a
crushing movie crushing you with the
wrong answer
is no answer the wrong answer
anyone Bueller get the wrong answer very
good the wrong answer 96 is a good
moodle's when you have better
professional athletes always wanting
more what that's the highest rated
player who is not mean Jonathan okay the
1,900 player who's underrated says rook
c6 is the threat for example after h6
and what most of you would like look
takes c6 now white threatening rip take
c8 checkmate with advantage so black
takes white takes and black loses all of
his pieces and cries also for King f8
you don't take all of his pieces you
made them okay so black has a lot of
problems and now his position is also
bad what were his problems before the
game
anybody remember yeah no but that's good
answer if I have a much funnier answer
you yes there's a kid who pays attention
to France so let's see already got
problems okay so don't step is easy oh
he plays it come sod slow food to sense
right food yeah yeah so he plays food is
that Bishop d7 and if you're watching on
YouTube from France to today
ok so he stops all of my threats so we
agreed to a draw
he said your proposal on noon and I said
quoi does that what happened it did and
all of you said quoi and then what a
Bugs Bunny say no he said quadrant if
doctor yeah pretty short well you're
laughing you get there what
that's what he says yeah that's people
fun Sabo
okay the rest of the lecture will be in
French which won't affect how much you
learn a phrase like that's right okay so
I played 96 as recommended by the kid
with the Michigan shirt where am i from
say Michigan yeah I was born in Michigan
unlike you were you born in Michigan you
see I was right and I lived in Harbor
for seven years
that's where Michigan is right now for
extra credit the stadium for Michigan
football what's the name of that stadium
you I'll give you a hint
ah I'll give you a head so some of you
will know this later in life it's the
same name as people they call it prison
when you go to the prison you go to the
no no you guys should know this because
you're going to need to know then I call
this the big house yeah and admission
again they played the big house yeah
also another Michigan players go to jail
so no words out okay now I'm just being
that Nebraska all right so he got out of
shot and then I took everything
then what did I do I called the doctor
because I hurt my arm taking his pieces
right did you don't might come as a
doctor did you know that you know why
you didn't know it because it's not true
okay so I put him in shock he got out of
check and now the computer says every
move wins and it says if it's black move
I'm winning and the truth hurts
I played nine eighty five and his King
is very safe as long as your definition
of safe is different than mine okay now
I want a piece and then I tried to check
medium because I got three pieces on his
king can i play it must be five because
I'm threatening Rick to be three checks
and then Rick before me whoa
that's the end of the report although it
wasn't working anyway so for example
after h5 a move most of you would make I
go check and chess made man my opponent
preferred not getting checkmated so he
played
instead of h5e king a for are attacking
my rug I moved my rook threatening Rigby
for me
he stopped early for me what move did he
make that stopped Rigby for me you and
the best with the right answer right now
if he was wrong a little terrible we had
to reshoot the whole thing he's fine now
I can't play hurt before
boohoo so I resigned no you know I'm a
grandmaster you're not so i played rough
a 5 minute and he had nothing to say
about it he was like yes sir
yeah right thanks no no you can't do
that okay so what movie did I make plays
okay five no having it this time is his
chest you I played her d5 threatening
wreck a5 me as I explained Rick a5 makes
easy to stop he stopped it by resigning
let's say he didn't resign and he made
the only move to stop such a 5 now I
have another maid who can find it the 2
o'clock class boys the same kid how
about you give incentive yet
nice c5 me now when you're done a piece
and you're getting needed I'm crushing
your pawns to Grandmaster most people
resign but if you place to me you
shouldn't play to one move before me in
any design you should let me be here
come on so after this I was like oh what
I'm going to meet him mixing with any
design it's only when I come in with
their to forfeit a double forfeit of it
ok that was my first game now as you all
know I am a grandmaster so I win every
game easily and my phones try ok except
that's not the truth the truth is much
worse
the truth is I'm losing all the time and
then my Punk's like yay I'm winning and
then they lose anyway yes
ok and that's what happened this game
okay I played a guy we had an 1800
what's my reason let's take a random
student Karen what's my rating plus tax
right so he's great eighteen hundred
with no tax and I'm we had 2500 with a
lot of tax hey don't know talking over
there so before the game is like oh I'm
gonna lose I'm the worst and he's right
and unfortunately for me he was winning
most of the game okay because I made a
mistake
I moved six but my first five was were
pretty good
right okay so in this position a very
complicated line is a five and then G
five I don't play complicated lines
because I'm old that is like a now let's
play a complicated line so I've ever
played he's fighting defy this was the
first time and here I made a mistake I
didn't make the kind of mistake you
would make you would play clean James b5
and they would fork your king and queen
I didn't do that yeah that's that's the
one Acosta two o'clock into three
o'clock last okay so the grand
minister's play Bishop c5 years that's
the normal rule okay I forgot what the
normal move was than I'd ever fight this
before so I played a six boo forcing his
nice a good square okay
now the computer says White has a really
good position because White's upon up
and I wait the time with these six so we
developed our pieces and he said oh boy
I'm up upon and I was like quiet we're
playing and in this position I sacrifice
another pawn now here he would like to
play he for that's what you would play
then what would I do
take his queen okay but he's great 1800
so he didn't do that he played Queen e1
he's going to play e4 next to move he's
a pawn up and he has a good center I
stopped him from playing eight for what
did I do
I play d4 now that was a pawn when I was
losing ones before you were born he
attacked my queen but I saw it
pretty good huh okay
and now he takes my phone on me for the
computer says he's up to climbs the
computer counts pretty well but he
played 83 not a good mood should take it
my father before then I attend all of
his night it's a double pin
it's like a double guitar right see the
double paradise so if he tries to take
my pawn he can't take with a knife as
his knife spit so I could just I can
just take so he unpinned his knight he
played Queen B 1 now it's nice snap
pinned he's attacking my pawn again he's
attacking my phone with everything he's
got
so I took at night and I attacked his
rock and the reason I attacked his rough
was I was hoping it would move away and
then I played Bishop to d3 BAM
well that's a good Bishop right great
Bishop what a bishop most of you would
take the bishop and I would take your
queen then you start crying so instead
he gave up Israel by taking my center
plot okay so in this position how many
extra Parvez 'we have good good try okay
count the number of pawns only only
count on what White has two extra pawns
and black has a working tonight for two
bishops supposedly a recognized better
than two bishops I doubt it and why does
a lot of extra clients and if my comers
watching the game he would just be in
the corner crying because it materials
too complicated for him there's no way
he could figure that out his flies at
all he would pay you to tell him what's
going on okay now I want to take all of
his pawns that I'm a mean guy so I play
Queen c5 now the reason having pawns is
good is because you promote them to
Queens he decided to do that now he
plays d6 he's attacking my Poland
so I played 95 now he can't take my
phone unless he cheats the computer
won't let me cheaters and he decided to
promote his fly and I was like dude
don't promote your pawn I want to win so
I claim here I'm like oh well I'm going
to take your fly and he's like stop
rubbing your hands it hurts my ear okay
so if he promotes this point he'll win
if I take his part that I'm doing okay
the computer says white is better but he
has to play correctly not his strong
suit he's not going to fight correctly
if he was playing correctly he'd be
ready 2809 1800 right 2,800 would like
correctly then I would lose I cry he
took my 9 which is correct he attacks my
queen which is correct and finally he
made a bad move finally he should have
played rip to d6 attacking my queen not
because of the text my queen but he
doesn't want my queen on his pawn he
wants me not to win his pawn so instead
he played Queen b3 and now I can win his
pawn then if I went in farm my position
is pretty good if I don't win as far my
positions that good okay and here you'll
notice I have two pieces attacking his
pawn because I said so how do I got that
other piece to attack his pawn and I
could take it yes I mean I wish I could
see a way to do it we think about it oh
wait I should put in training so you
don't cheat you with the right answer I
was going to play these five I changed
my mind
Queen him Oh move my King to e7 but no
these five is the right idea I didn't do
it the reason I didn't do it is because
he plays Queen d4 and I assume your
ideas Rick a7 is that right you know I
can't play rook a seven
you told me okay you and the bass was
something crazy to say hang on I was
right
I was more right than I've ever been in
my life with anything
Brooke she it's the craziest move on the
board good job that he takes what I
wrote was it fun oh good answer
all right mind me to give you some money
later okay so I want to move my feet
part and play rook a7 but I was afraid
of Queen d4 so I played b6 narrow I'm
going to play rook age seven and take
his pawn array for me
the computer says that's for Queen f5
it's an equal position both sides could
win or a draw but he played Queen d5
which the computer says is bad then we
traded Queens and I played rooking seven
and he can't stop me for winning his
pawn so you have a passed pawn and you
push it your opponent takes it that's
not good what's good for them so he took
my pawn and I took his opponent now he
has a bishop and two points for a look
which is about the same except his bones
are no good boom okay I'm going to go
take those pawns
so instead of me going to take them he
moved them towards me so I could taste
them he's a nice guy
he played c4 I decided to trap his rook
with f6 now his rook can go anywhere in
stuff isn't it that looks not so good on
the side one of your chest teachers
before me how old he said don't put your
pieces on the side hey you said I'll do
what I want then your books on the side
they can't move anywhere okay so he
played c5 he thought I would take and
then he would take and he's happy okay
but I know attacks it called removing
the defender his rook is defending his
pawn so I got his work out of there I
played
what v6 is like the reverse of what you
wanted to say other side of the board
you have the right move you're just
saying along g6 yeah yeah
now you with some crazy line defense the
rook we talking about g6 never never
mind is trapped g6 he plays obvious move
not obvious to you but there's an IC
hundred player behind it's obvious to
him
oh you eight-six
yeah he plays hurricane six then I went
dumb yum yum now I have a fast five now
he has a passport I take it I have a
passport I promoted work age seven what
whoo okay so thanks chat here and now I
have a plan that's my plan
good plan huh yeah watch watch me do it
he moved his Russia this attack and I
did my plan then he treated rooks was
the computer says is terrible for him
and then I did my plan that he's like
man I like that plan so he gave up if
you want to stop my porn he has to do it
with his bishop but they ain't gonna
work is it and I mean he's going to go
with Bishop for the party that he'll
make some move and I'll clean and then
I'm doing I'll up a rug I'm the best but
probably does a lot of dry answers
better yeah
so after c3 he resigned hooray for me
that after the game he's like I was
winning the most famous quote from any
chess player I was winning yeah yeah you
was winning until you wasn't so he
played really well that came and he all
these extra pawns he pushed his pawn and
so I took it unfortunate
so if you look past blonde and you're
promoting it no one desert I take it
because then those one doesn't work now
the last game was the easiest and my
opponent just like the first trying to
follow this she didn't castle and then
she's like man like Kings been doing too
well and I was like no talking during
the game none of the kids thought that
by the way any bulk either okay so she
did something that you've really heard
of I played the Queen's Gambit your
favorite opening and she took that's the
queen gambit accepted okay and not the
way you installed at the correct way
with a name right like when you give me
a million dollars I accept it right okay
and all you kids are good except you
kids of the middle that's accepted with
Annie right but I still want them in the
room because this so they're accepted
with an a number there's nothing the
kids got nothing they're looking on the
ceiling going is the answer there I
don't see it the answer is on the
ceiling
okay now I'm not a pawn so I played III
to take my phone back now I'm going to
show you a trap I learned when I was
younger than you I was younger than you
are L in this trap b5 defending his
pawns
a4 c6 defending his pawn
say no talking now look on now White has
a winning move incorrect does somebody
want to suggest a legal move here what's
a legal move correct
can you can you walk him to the water
clock class back in the past now you
said the right moving tilde notation
will get it again to the right notation
there you go Queen f3
now his look is attacked because I said
so and he's gonna lose some pieces or
something he's going to lose a bishop
and now you're a rock it's actually
happening or Queen now if he loses a
queen he still has to lose more that
doesn't really help okay so I played III
nobody's ever done that I saw the book
when nobody ever does it and we played
all these boring moves pretty boring
okay and we got this position and I want
to play e5 rawr
so I did BAM and my opponent was reading
about 2180 she saw her Knight with the
tat so she moved in not only that she
attacked my pawn three times and it's
protected two times so I protected it
again what did I do
mission f4 is what I played some of you
would protect with your roof and then
when your phone lines here you go on and
you start crying
I played through that for now she did
something you guys do a lot she thought
for a long time
okay here's what she should do is break
my rule never play f6 that's what she
should play and that's actually I find
again and the computer says white is
slightly better but she played b6 and
she's being headed her Bishop and I put
my knight on e4 rar and she's like you
can't take my bishop but I was going to
take your Bishop so she moved it away i
took her bishop anyway I just went here
Grandmaster I played 96 Chet that's a
pretty good night so she took it and she
went here now I discovered a good move
discovered oh this one was recommended
by Christopher Columbus usually he
didn't discover anything okay the
world's biggest lie okay so notice if I
move my knight my queen is attacking her
Knight right you notice that so I played
Knight g5 and she was like hmm if I move
my knight then I'm going to go wham okay
and then George Michael would turn over
in his grave
none you kids heard of Williams you
don't get it okay what about you nothing
you got nothing these famous because
using a group called lamb also ex clam
that went with excellent
weren't you Eliza Blaine I see d6 oh
yeah do you ever heard of them they make
a joke of it on Family Guy they're like
and now vh1 back in the music with the
other guy from Lambie I think this is
injured rigidly but
but I'm sure getting a lot of comments
about that know his name was suction
touch
no talking now after 96 fe6 Bishop e6
the truth hurts it's the only good
sacrifice you're ever going to see for
me it's Queens not stress also her queen
what can she do the only state square
you should all know it's the two o'clock
last Karen Queens e8 now I think a lot
of moves win but my intention was Bishop
c8 because she's in check and then I
take her Bishop and I take every piece
that was a good intention I thought
anyway June like any of that so she
played the trickiest move you've ever
seen recommended by Run DMC you get that
at least or that one you go yeah that's
the trickiest after 86 forcing me to
play the winning sacrifice were hard and
now it's even stronger okay so she
played 95 giving away her knife so I was
like I take a night and I'm up at night
then she did a fork which I knew she
would do that's why she played 95 how
did she threaten my unprotected bishop
and threatened chef made two for one you
with the right answer
yeah I knew as you say Queen us I'll get
that money I didn't call right
yeah do you dyslexic you can some new
prescription for glasses right you
didn't always reversing Tony would be
like Queen C 3 a queen s priests funnier
okay
Queen C six threatening my bishops and
threatening me
it wouldn't work looks like it worse
alright so I have a lot of ways to win
ice lady seven shots that's the most
complicated right is that okay if she
takes of the Queen all those threats she
just made aren't there anymore her
Queens going on seasick threats are gone
if she takes with the king a lot of
moves win every move winds ripped d1
check is the simplest because then I
could just send me or I could play the
a4 ventured Bishop g5 other things
window so she plays the best move King
g7 I stop me Knight f3 and she took back
her piece
BAM okay now I plays the crushing move
now it's too hard for this class so I'll
give you a hint it's check there's only
like seven or eight checks here so you
can probably get it you have a chance
I'm going to count all the check and
you're going to count all the chests and
you're going to be wrong and I'm going
to be right
I guarantee it nobody will be right
maybe Jonathan meaning about you know
talking accounting okay I sounded all
the chests white is raise your hand how
many Tesla's way who says four raise
your hands who says five who said sit in
Johnson's room and who says seven the
radiance sir they're like what's the
right answer okay Jonathan did you miss
da bishop
so Queen C 526 Queen e6 Queen Esther
Queens you find which ones you guys five
plus two do oh you saw all this you kind
of think the truth hurts yeah so this is
check this is all check and Bishop and
Queen one of those taxes that move I
played the best one cause
well I didn't promote so now you was the
right answer it's hard to be one now
because the other checks are all
horrible Queen g5 now if black plays the
move you would play then I would fork
the king and queen so she didn't do that
and if she plays King f8 that's even
worse
how did we find a worst movement he
would fight because I go here and I make
a rough as I'm funny
it does matter a knight or a bishop of
Terra
still winning and then me okay
and she can break my rule never play f6
she could the computer says white is
plus 11 here the computer likes white so
she plays the other move that one I
didn't show you yet we're like you
didn't show us a who's what anyone
what's the only move I didn't show you
is she played it you that's right I
didn't show you King g8 and the stupid
computer won't let me do it what a dumb
computer I can't do it so I got myself
no King bee sting bee it's illegal
kingi sit but King g8 was insisted upon
by the one o'clock class they refused to
look at anything else
kingi is blocking the path farm again
and now members of mate that she was
threatening before with queen g2 that's
never going to happen because my Queens
defending g2 so there's no more threats
for black ever so it's my turn to make
threat now you were taught to play chess
by somebody probably not very good
because I watching this play and today
for you to put your king on g6 in the
opening and they didn't know why you
keep doing it what you dr. Morris ok so
I played 95 forking everything it's not
very fair I'm threatening Knight takes
Queen and Knight takes f7 everything's a
fork can I wake the Kings side and I
gave them some of the fork so they could
serve people right yeah they're running
out of forks
okay now she did what you guys never do
G resign and the computer says like plus
ten and the reason is there's a reason
if you move your Queens to a random
square that's a regular it looks like I
just win the exchange I win a knife for
a rug but the problem is if she takes my
knight I win that rook - okay you can't
get all your hooks away so the computer
is like man this is bad and she was like
man this is bad so she gave up okay and
then she bought a ten pack of lessons
Wow I mean yay right the truth hurts
yeah so then I'll teach her for ten
hours and then she'll beat you the next
game but I won't show you that game
Katie questions any questions from home
now now that's 50/50 this recording
device worked when I say 5050 I mean
like $1.99 yeah yeah so this part will
climb the internet but does it's a
miracle also last week's was recorded
perfectly cool on the internet so there
you go
you could try to get on today because
it's Father's Day when I record videos
on my channel the ruffed like 10 minutes
it's the highest quality possible--
Clemente really horrible yeah people
comment on my videos like oh boo that it
says that fat sighs and the next comment
is just morose keeps telling that
couldn't believe it
one time I was eating this soup alphabet
soup and it was a ghost
it spelled blue and I was like no and
then my friend was like those are
Cheerios okay I remember the most
important thing nobody could definitely
class dismissed
you
[Music]